on va tout de suite prendre la direction
de washington où joe biden va s'exprimer
dans quelques instants
l'armée russe à en lancer une agression
contre l'ukraine sans provocation sans
justification sans nécessité il s'agit
d'une attaque préméditée la limite
poutine après voyez cette attaque
pendant des mois comme nous l'avons dit
il a déplacé plus de cent soixante
quinze mille soldats équipements
militaires qui la pré positionnées le
long de la frontière kenyane et il a
déplacé des réserves de sang sur place
et a créé un hôpital de terrain qui
montraient qu'elles étaient ses agents
ses intentions il a rejeté tout effort
de bonne foi de la part des états unis
dé ses alliés de ses partenaires ce fait
pour répondre à nos préoccupations
par le biais du dialogue pour éviter un
conflit inutile et éviter toute
souffrance pendant des semaines pendant
des semaines nous avons averti que ce
cela se produirait aujourd'hui nous
voyons ces événements se dérouler comme
nous l'avions prévu cette semaine nous
avons vu de plus en plus de
bombardements de donbass à cette région
à l'est de l'ukraine contrôlée par les
séparatistes le gouvernement russe a
interprété des actions des cyberattaques
contre l'ukraine nous avons vu
nous avons vu des informations diffusées
et disons que l'ukraine allait envahir
et le lancer une guerre contre la russie
que l'ukraine était en train d'utiliser
ou à les utiliser des armes chimiques
enrique reine avaient étaient en train
de perpétrer un génocide sans aucun
élément factuel sans aucune preuve nous
avons vu une grande violation du droit
international
avec une tentative de créer deux
soi-disant république sur le territoire
souverain de l'ukraine
et au moment où les le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies se
réunissaient pour
se tenir aux côtés de l'ukraine poutine
a déclaré sa guerre
des bombardements ont commencé sur les
villes d'ukraine
cela a été suivi par une arrivée de
tanks dans les villes nous avons été
transparents avec le monde nous avons
partagé des informations déclassifiées
sur le plan sur les plans de la russie
les faux prétextes les hivernales pour
qu'il n'y ait aucune confusion qu'il n'y
a rien de secret sur ce que poutine ne
faisait poutine et l'agresseur poutine a
choisi cette guerre est aujourd'hui lui
et son pays souffriront des conséquences
aujourd'hui autorisent une de nouvelles
la sanction une nouvelle série de
sanctions et de nouvelles limites sur ce
qui peut être exportées vers la russie
cela soir ont un coût et graves sur
l'économie russe aujourd'hui et à
l'avenir nous avons conçu cet ensemble
de sanctions afin de maximiser les
impacts à long terme sur la russie et
minimiser l'impact sur les états unis et
nos alliés et je tiens à être clair sur
une chose les états unis ne sont pas
seuls dans cet exercice depuis des mois
nous développons à une coalition de
partenaires qui représentent plus de la
moitié des économies du monde 27 membres
de l'union européenne y compris la
france l'allemagne l'italie ainsi que le
royaume-uni le canada le japon
l'australie la nouvelle-zélande et bien
d'autres pour amplifier l'impact
conjointe de notre réponse je viens de
m'entretenir avec les dirigeants du g7
ce matin et nous sommes totalement
d'accord nous allons limiter la capacité
de la russie à travailler avec le rôle
le dollar le yen pour nuire à sa
participation limitée sa participation à
l'économie mondiale nous allons miner sa
capacité à financer et à développer se
sont armés nous allons les empêcher a
travaillé dans l'économie de dieu
technologique du 21e siècle nous avons
déjà vu l'impact que cela avait sur le
rouble
aujourd'hui le rouble atteint son niveau
le plus faible sont plus faibles
historiquement la bourse russa s'est
effondré aujourd'hui le gouvernement
russe a vu son taux de d'ampera augmenté
de 50% et aujourd'hui
nous imposant des sanctions contre les
russes qui détiennent plus de mille
milliards de dollars d'actifs assez
ses banques qui détiennent plus raide un
tiers des actifs russes ont été coupés
du système financier et aujourd'hui nous
bloquons également 4 + bancs
supplémentaires cela signifie que tout
actif à leur disposition aux états unis
sera gelé cela inclut vitib y est la
deuxième plus grande banque russe qui a
250 milliards de dollars d'actifs
comme promis nous ajoutons également le
calcul le nom d'élite russe est l'homme
des membres de leur famille
qui souffriront de sanctions comme je
les dis à mardi il s'agit de personnes
qui ont personnellement gagné bénéficié
des politiques du kremlin qui doivent
souffrir des conséquences
nous maintiendrons cette pression sur
les personnes un corrompu dans les jours
à venir mardi nous avons empêché le
gouvernement russe de lever des fonds de
la part d'investisseurs européens ou
américains nous allons appliquer les
mêmes sanctions aux grands entreprises
publiques russes des entreprises avec
des actifs acquis dépasse 1
2400 milliards de dollars certains de
l'impact de certaines de ses actions à
hébron avec le temps alors que nous
réduisons l'accès de la russie à des
technologies pour dans les secteurs
stratégiques de son économie et pour
miner ses capacités industrielles pour
les années à venir avec nos actions et
les actions de nos alliés et partenaires
nous estimons que nous allons pouvoir
couper la moitié des importations high
tech de la russie cela infligerait un
coup à ce gouvernement qui cherche à
renforcer son armée
et qui cela mènera également son
programme spatial
cela réduira leur capacité à bâtir à des
navires à développer leur économie et ce
sera un grand coup porté à la grande
ambition de poutine et nous sommes prêts
à faire plus en plus des sanctions
économiques que nous allons imposer nous
prenons des mesures pour défendre nos
alliés de l'otan en particulier à l'est
demain l'otan va tenir un sommet nous
serons présents pour réunir les
dirigeants de 30 nations allié et
partenaire de choix pour réaffirmer
notre solidarité et pour préparer les
prochaines étapes les prochaines mesures
que nous prenons pour renforcer tous les
aspects de notre alliance au sein de
l'otan bien que nous ayons à porter aux
650 millions de dollars que nous avions
apporté 650 millions de dollars en aide
à l'ukraine cette année et l'an dernier
je tiens à répéter que nos forces armées
ne sont pas et ne seront pas de déployer
pour participer au conflit en ukraine
nos forces armées ne n'iront pas en
ukraine n'iront pas en europe mais nous
irons en europe défendre nos alliés de
l'otan comme je l'exprimé avec beaucoup
de clarté les états unis vont défendre
chaque centimètre carré de territoires
de l'otan avec toute la force de la
puissance américaine et la bonne
nouvelle est que l'otan est aujourd'hui
plus unie plus déterminé que jamais il
ne fait aucun doute aucun doute que les
états unis et tous les alliés de l'otan
respecteront leurs engagements en vertu
de l'article 5 qui dit qu'une attaque
contre un membre est une attaque contre
tous les membres de l'otan ces dernières
semaines j'ai déployé plus de 2 quelques
milliers de soldats en allemagne en
pologne mardi en réaction à l'agression
de la russie
dans la mer noire et dans le bus j'ai
demandé un déploiement des forces déjà
disposé en europe elle dépasse ses
formes à l'est de l'europe en estonie
lettonie lituanie en pologne en roumanie
nos alliés ont déjà renforcé leurs
efforts
le reste de l'otan a renforcé ses forces
et ses capacités afin d'assurer notre
défense collective est aujourd'hui à
quelques heures de l'assaut de la russie
l'otan s'est réuni et a autorisé
un plan de réaction un plan d'activation
de réac de riposte cela permettra aux
forces de l'otan de se déployer l'âme et
où elles sont nécessaires pour protéger
nos alliés de l'otan sur le front est de
l'europe j'autorise aujourd'hui
davantage de capacités américaines à
être déployés en allemagne dans le cadre
de l'arrêt poste de l'otan y compris
certaines forces américaines qui
appartiennent à une force qui est en
stand by depuis quelques semaines j'ai
également par les eaux
à différents secrétaires généraux à
différents généraux pour nous préparer à
différents déploiements s'il est
nécessaire de déployer davantage de
forces pour protéger nos alliés de
l'otan et soutenir la plus grande force
alliée de l'histoire l'otan
mon administration utilise tous les
outils à notre disposition pour protéger
les familles américaines et les
entreprises américaines dunod montée des
prix et d'une montée des prix à la pompe
tonne nous mettons en place des mesures
pour réduire les coûts et les
entreprises américaines de pétrole hier
ne devrait pas utiliser cette occasion
pour augmenter le les prix et faire plus
de profits dans notre paquet de défauts
de mesures nous avons décidé de
continuer à suivre l'approvisionnement
énergétique pour éviter toute
perturbation nous sont coordonnées avec
les grandes grands pays producteurs de
pétrole avec un intérêt partagé pour
assurer l'approvisionnement nous
travaillons avec les différents pays
dans le monde pourra
utiliser les réserves de pétrole
disponible et les etats unis ont
également
ont également déployé plus de barils de
pétrole pour répondre à cette demande je
sais que le peuple américain souffre le
souffre déjà j'aimerais tout ce qui est
en mon pouvoir pour elle limiter les
souffrances ressentie par les américains
à la pompe c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel pour moi toutefois cette
agression ne peut pas
d'y être
nous devons réagir face à la frustration
nous y sommes unis pour la liberté voilà
qui nous sommes
et je tiens à répéter l'avertissement
que j'ai prononcé la semaine dernière si
la russie continue à faire des cyber
attaques contre nos entreprises nos
infrastructures critiques nous sommes
prêts à réagir et a riposté pendant
depuis des mois nous travaillons en
étroite collaboration avec le secteur
privé pour renforcer notre défense cyber
renforcer notre capacité à riposter aux
attaques cyber de la russie je me suis
entretenu hier soir avec le président
lenski le président ukrainien et je les
assurer que les états unis aux côtés de
nos alliés de nos partenaires européens
soutiendront le peuple ukrainien qui
cherche à défendre son pays nous vous
apporterons une aide humanitaire a pour
alléger vos souffrances et en début de
ce conflit et les entreprises de
propagande aux russes vont continuer à
chercher à cacher la vérité
mais l'histoire a montré encore et
encore à quel point les prises de
territoire rapide finissent par une
occupation longue entre engendre une des
opinions une désobéissance civile est
une impasse
les mois et semaines et mois à venir
seront difficiles pour les ukrainiens
toutefois le peuple ukrainien a connu 30
30 ans d'indépendance ils ont montré à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils ne laisseront
personne n'a essayé de leur voler leur
pays
nous vivons un moment dangereux en
europe pour la liberté dans le monde
poutine a lancé une agression contre la
paix internationale contre ce principe a
mais aujourd'hui le monde entier voit
clairement ce que poutine et ses alliés
au kremlin souhaite faire qu'ils sont
réellement
ce n'était jamais une préoccupation de
sécurité authentique de l'heure pour eux
c'était tout simplement une agression
pure et simple le désir de poutine de
restaurer un empire par tous les moyens
possibles en intimidant en intimidant
ses voisins en modifiant de force les
frontières et aujourd'hui en choisissant
une guerre sans aucune
raison
poutine ne cherche à imposer sa vision
du monde où on peut prendre les choses
par la force mais c'est une vision que
les états unis et les nations qui aiment
la liberté
combattrons avec toute notre force et
tous nos outils les etats-unis nos
alliés et partenaires or en sortiront
plus grand plus unie plus déterminé et
plus résolue de cette guerre l'agression
de poutine contre l'ukraine a eu le
coûtera cher
économiquement et stratégiquement à la
russie nous nous en assurerons
poutine sera un paria sur la scène
internationale toute nation
toute nation qui participent à cette
agression sera entaché
dans l'histoire
l'histoire montrera que le choix de
poutine aura affaibli la russie et or a
renforcé le reste du monde la liberté la
démocratie la dignité humaine voilà les
forces des forces bien plus puissante
que la peur et l'oppression
ces principes ne peuvent mourir ne
peuvent être écrasé par l'armée de
poutine c'est le principe ne peuvent
être balayés barre à
la violence et l'intimidation d'où ces
principes survivront survivront dans la
compétition entre l'autocratie la
démocratie entre la souveraineté la
subjugation ne vous méprenez pas la
liberté l'emportera
que dieu bénisse
la population de l'ukraine libre et que
dieu protège nos soldats
x de la société de presse
avez vous l'intention de vous entretenir
avec président poutine
j'ai entendu la première question est ce
que j'ai l'intention de m'entretenir
avec poutine et
avez vous communiquez avec le kremlin
concernant les opérations militaires en
ukraine pour éviter que cela sans
entraîner un conflit plus grand c'est
déjà un grand conflit
et pour éviter que cela ne s'aggrave eh
bien nous allons apporter suffisamment
de force mon flanc est de l'europe dans
le cadre de l'otan le je n'ai pas
l'intention de m'entretenir avec poutine
selon le wall street journal une terrine
à
parler de swift dans vos sanctions que
vous avez annoncé est ce qu'il ya une
raison pour lesquelles les états unis
hn1 sud n'expulse pas là aussi du
système swift est ce qu'il ya un
désaccord avec les alliés et est ce que
la
nba les sanctions que nous proposons sur
les autres banques ont déjà des grandes
conséquences plus de conséquences que
l'exclusion du programme swift a
premièrement deuxièmement c'est toujours
une option mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
la position
que nous souhaitons adopter
cécilia vega haïti
les sanctions n'ont pas suffi à
dissuader vladimir poutine tend vers
l'ukraine que qu'est-ce qui peut
l'arrêter quand et comment mettre un
terme à cette attaque et avez vous
l'intention d'aller plus loin que
l'ukraine
deuxièmement la déclaration qu'il a
faite y est
la menacer l'occident disant que
l'occident allait subir de plus grande
tension est ce qu'il menace d'une
attaque nucléaire
alors je ne sais pas du tout quelles
sont ces menaces je sais ce qu'il a fait
c'est la première chose et deuxièmement
personne ne s'attendait à ce que les
sanctions dissuasives empêche quelque
chose d'arriver
cela va prendre du temps et nous devons
nous montrer résolus afin que poutine
sache ce qui va générer pour que les
russes sache ce qui leur impose voilà la
porte et l'utilité de saison cela va
prendre du temps les il ne va pas dire
oh mon dieu c'est sanction arrive je
vais retirer les troupes non il va
tester la résolution de l'occident pour
voir si nous restons d'euros unis et
nous allons rester unis nous allons
imposer un coût
bien est ce que vous pensez qu'il ira
plus loin que l'ukraine
deux questions très rapidement par les
marchés elles se sont effondrées et le
prix du gaz a augmenté je sais que vous
avez toujours insisté sur la différence
entre wall street et le reste de la
société mais tout le monde semble
ressentir une des difficultés
économiques jusqu'où ira-t-on ou
alors premièrement il ne fait aucun
doute que lorsqu'une grande 9 puissances
nucléaires attaqué en veille un autre
pays
il ne fait aucun doute que le monde va
réagir éclairage les marchés vont réagir
dans le monde entier c'est la première
chose et deuxièmement la notion que
c'est quelque chose qui va durer
longtemps et très peu probable tant que
nous continuons à restait résolu et
qu'en tant que nous continuons à imposer
des sanctions les sanctions que nous
allons imposer à la russie j'ai oublié
votre deuxième question la deuxième
question est ce que vous avez
sous-estimé poutine
et est ce que vous le qualité toujours
d'adversaires digne comme vous l'avez
dit l'an dernier la dernière je sais ce
que j'ai dit mais je ne vais pas
sous-estimer
j'ai lu la plupart des choses qu'il a
écrite
vous avez entendu son discours
plus d'une heure
deux discours qui expliquait pourquoi
elle allait envahir l ukraine il a des
ambitions bien plus grande que l'ukraine
il souhaite rétablir
l'urss voilà ce qu'il soit de faire et
je pense que ces ambitions
sont totalement contraires
à la ou le monde est arrivé aujourd'hui
pensez vous que ces sanctions
dévastatrice vont être aussi
dévastatrice que lé
les balaie les
missiles et les temps que russe alors
oui il y a des tanks qui ont des effets
dévastateurs mais les sanctions auront
un effet dévastateur sur la russie si
les sanctions n'empêche pas la nicotine
d'avancé qu'est-ce qui peut le faire je
n'ai pas dit que les sanctions allaient
pouvoir l'arrêter mais vous avez parlé
de ces sanctions pendant de menaces de
sanctions alors les menaces de sanctions
et imposer une sanction ce sont deux
choses différentes
ce sont deux choses différentes
à présent il va commencer à voir à
l'effet des sanctions
et qu'est-ce que cela fera comment cela
va changer son état d'esprit et bien
parce que cela va affaiblir énormément
son pays quand et si bien qu'il devra
faire un choix très difficile soif ou
continuer
à envahir ou ou s'arrêter vous avez dit
que on ne n'y a pas de bluff vous avez
parlé
de sanctions contre vladimir poutine est
ce que c'est une mesure coûteuse alors
ce n'est pas un bluff ce sont des
sanctions sur les sanctions contre de la
lumière poutine pourquoi ne pas imposer
des sanctions contre lui dès aujourd'hui
pourquoi ne pas imposer des sanctions
contre vladimir poutine dès aujourd'hui
monsieur le président vous avez
détailler de nouvelles sanctions lourdes
et natives qui auront un impact sur la
durée mais étant donné
à l'ampleur de cette invasion étant
donné que vous n'allez pas déconnecter
la russie du système international
bancaire swift et où que vous n'allez
pas eu d'autres sanctions
sauf votre respect qu'attendez vous
nous avons imposé des sanctions et ces
sanctions vont au delà au delà de
l'exclusion de swift les sanctions
devant imposé
aux côtés des deux tiers du monde sont
des sanctions lourdes massive âge
dans un mois nous verrons s'il
fonctionne
vous avez vous êtes entretenu avec la
biennale inscrit hier
quel est le risque que nous soyons
confrontés à une nouvelle bière froide
et qu'il y ait une totale c'est parce
qu'il ya une rupture des relations entre
les etats-unis et la russie il y à une
rupture de nos relations
et concernant la guerre froid avait bien
mais cela dépend vous avez la mas stes
la vaste majorité du monde qui est
totalement opposée à l'action de poutine
de l'asie jusqu'à l'amérique latine en
passant par l'europe le monde entier
et donc cela va être une journée froide
pour la rue si vous ne voyez pas
beaucoup de personnes venir à sa défense
encouragez-vous la chine des cdd à
isoler la la russie
je ne suis pas prêt à faire un
commentaire sur ce sujet pour le moment
[Musique]
non non non
enfin moment qu'il avait déjà levé la
main merci monsieur le président est
occupée par le fait que petit ne
souhaite un horaire d'autres pays est ce
qu'il faudra intervenir davantage s'ils
envahi un pays de l'otan oui s'il a
envahi un pays de l'otan que nous
interviendrons mais le fait est que si
nous n'intervenons pas s'ils ne nous
opposons pas à lui dès aujourd'hui avec
la saison sur massive et bien elle sera
renforcée dans son ambition de
votre condamnation
monsieur le président
[Musique]
pourquoi ne pas imposer des sanctions
contre poutine dès aujourd'hui
est un grand partenaire des états unis
est ce que l'inde est à vos côtés pour
condamner la russie
de grands partenaires en matière de
défense est ce que l'inde est également
aux côtés de la russie pour se poser là
aussi nous travaillons en consultation
avec l'inde nous n'avons pas encore
résolu tous les tous les points
merci beaucoup
et c'était donc la prise de parole de
joe biden